today on the best-selling children's
authors show chicago public schools are
excited to announce that every bathroom
in the district in every school will now
be gender neutral now how could they
instate a policy like this right on the
heels of the loudoun county scandal
where a girl was raped in a bathroom by
a boy in address we'll talk about that
today also the white house unveils its
new five-point plan for defeating kovid
will this work better than the plan they
had before this or the one before that
the one before that and whoopi goldberg
engages in shocking transphobia while
attacking pro-lifers the new york times
argues that abortion is good because
adoption is bad and trevor noah takes
the vaccine red pill an unexpected turn
of events we'll talk about all of that
much more today on the best-selling
children's author
[Music]
have you gotten
the get upside app yet i've been telling
you about it um i don't know what you're
waiting for if you have not gone and to
google uh play right now or the app
store
and um taken advantage of that i don't
know what you're waiting for because get
upside is all upside there's no downside
to it you're saving money every time you
go to the pump my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up use promo code
walsh and get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free and use promo code walsh to get
up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on your
first tank some people who drive a lot
and do a lot of traveling
are making two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back and there's no
catch the cash back gets added to your
account it's as simple as that you can
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal you can get an e-gift card to
amazon or somewhere else and if you want
this
just go download the free get upside app
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cash back on your first
tank again that's the free get upside
app use promo code walsh for 50 cents a
gallon cashback
so the kids who attend chicago public
schools don't have it easy they live in
one of the most violent and crime-ridden
places in the country as of november 1st
678 people had been murdered in the city
outpacing the murder rate from 2020
which was itself historically high
homelessness is also on the rise along
with drug abuse and nearly every marker
of
societal disintegration the poverty rate
in chicago is 20
these dire conditions can be felt in the
school system itself where the violence
from the street often spills into the
hallways and the classrooms as you might
expect the schools are so infected and
surrounded by violence that many
students are scared to walk home at the
end of the day earlier this year two
15-year-old students at one chicago
school were shot and killed in separate
shootings on the same day near the
school they attended
this is what it's like to attend class
inside a war zone basically
academically chicago schools are subpar
at best their elementary age students
are below the national average in both
math and reading the situation is so bad
that the school system brags about a
graduation rate of only 82 percent
also considerably below the national
average granted it's an improvement from
the catastrophic 60 graduation rate of
2007
but still not very good all in all
suffice it to say that chicago public
schools have problems
major problems
and they aren't focused on solving any
of them
instead the district has set inclusivity
as one of its primary goals and it most
especially wants to impose inclusivity
in the bathrooms
now as a normal insane person you have
probably been inside hundreds of public
restrooms and never once thought to
yourself that the environment needed to
be more inclusive
it's likely that you've you you have
never looked around and said yeah i
really wish there was a more diverse
array of people
uh peeing alongside me
you may take note of many other
improvements that can be made inside any
particular public restroom most of them
hygiene and sanitation related but
diversity and inclusivity were probably
not among them
but the chicago public school system
like so many other school systems is not
run by people like you
it's run by weirdos and predators and
perverts who have never met a
heteronormative quote unquote
arrangement that they don't want to
dismantle
and that's why the district announced
this week that all bathrooms and all of
its schools at every grade level will be
made gender-neutral from henceforward
they proudly released a video where kami
pratt and deb spraggins
their top title ix officers and chief
groomers
announced the change let's watch this
hello everyone i'm cammy pratt the
district's chief title 9 officer and i'm
debs fraggins the district's deputy
chief title 9 officer the new school
year is off to a strong start as we've
welcomed our students back to our school
buildings five days each week on top of
ensuring that each of our schools is a
safe learning environment we're also
taking steps to create more inclusive
and supportive schools
one change that will be implemented this
school year relates to our school
bathrooms in compliance with new federal
guidelines all cps students and staff
will have fair and equitable access to
bathroom facilities that align with
their gender identity we will be
providing all schools with updated
signage that makes our bathrooms more
inclusive it will identify the fixtures
available in each restroom and make it
clear that all restrooms are open for
use by anyone who feels comfortable
staff will continue to have staff only
restrooms available to them this is an
incredibly important step to increase
gender equity for all which is why we
will be requiring all schools to post
this signage by december 1st of this
school year
our district's office of student
protections and title 9 is also working
on a long-term plan to create more
permanent signage for our bathrooms i
encourage you to visit our website at
cps.edu
forward slash osp to learn more about
our comprehensive approach to creating
more inclusive equitable and safe
schools
if you have any questions you can email
us at osp
cps.edu we look forward to having a safe
and successful school year at every
school in every neighborhood across
chicago thank you
and to make the dystopian feel uh you
know the dystopian theme to make it
complete of course we have in the video
footage of kids walking around with
masks on their face the signage on the
bathrooms will read boys plus and girls
plus with a note indicating that quote
all who feel comfortable are welcome to
use this restroom
this of course does not take into
account the fact that for most
well-adjusted people their comfort level
in the bathroom depends on who else is
allowed to use it
most girls feel comfortable using the
girls restroom because there will only
be girls inside it
these girls will not feel comfortable if
anyone else if anyone else who feels
comfortable regardless of sex is allowed
to join them
the upshot is that normal girls with a
normal desire for privacy and safety
will not feel comfortable anywhere now
in chicago public schools there's no
restroom for them to use
for the sake of providing comfort to the
tiny minority of gender non-conformists
the comfort of everybody else must be
sacrificed
for normal girls that is a cis girls as
they're now called in an effort to
marginalize normalcy
the signs ought to simply say go to hell
we don't care about you
because after all that is the message
this is not about comfort generally
speaking and it's not about being
inclusive or tolerant
if the policy was motivated by those
desires i'd still oppose it
because inclusivity tolerance and
comfort cannot be the overriding
concerns in a bathroom or really
anywhere else in life but as it happens
those are not the concerns here at all
as always the predators and groomers are
using these nice sounding words as
window dressing for their true agenda in
this case the real point is to institute
a social hierarchy where the desires of
the uber victims those in the lgbt camp
especially trans people are placed
explicitly above
the needs of those who are their
inferiors
normal girls and boys
are punished for being normal
these are basically punitive measures
these punitive measures have by design a
sort of if you can't beat em join them
effect after a while kids are so
immersed in gender ideology so subject
to its commands even in bathrooms that
eventually they're worn down and they
learn to accept it and then after a
while embrace it
you've probably already taken note of
the timing of this bathroom policy
change in chicago it comes directly on
the heels of a of a of a major national
scandal in loudoun county that we
uncovered here at the daily wire where a
girl was brutally raped inside a girl's
bathroom by a boy in a dress now some on
social media have said that they they
can't believe that chicago would instate
this policy
in spite of what happened in virginia
but they're wrong
chicago is not doing this now in spite
of the loudoun county scandal
they're doing it now because of that
scandal
the groomers and predators and
brainwashers of children are not backing
away in shame
because that happened
they certainly won't change course out
of any concern for the safety of
children they don't care if kids are
raped in the bathroom they don't care
they only care if the raping becomes
inconvenient to the trans agenda
the well-being of children is not a
priority at all
it does not factor into the equation
they don't think about it
and that is not an
exaggeration i guarantee you in chicago
when they were coming up with this
policy and talking about it
no one even said
well are we worried about girls
their well-being i mean we were worried
about their safety
what if they what if they end up getting
abused or raped in the bath
that's not not an issue they don't care
what matters is that every aspect of
student life conforms with the demands
of leftist ideology and especially
gender ideology and any amount of
suffering is a worthy trade
towards that end
that's why chicago is doing this now
they're doubling down
they're sending a message to the
domestic terrorists i.e parents who
value their children's safety and
well-being and the message is uh your
kids are ours
we own them
we will do what we want with them and to
them
i said before that chicago isn't focused
on addressing the violence and chaos in
its schools
and uh that's true but i i should
mention that they did announce this year
a new plan what they call a healing
centered framework
to help kids cope with trauma related to
violence covet and other struggles it's
not clear what this will entail exactly
but we do know that it will cost 25
million dollars whatever they do with it
i wonder if the girls who will now be
abused raped harassed and accosted in
the school's bathrooms will have access
to those healing-centered services
something tells me they will not
because their trauma doesn't count
just like their feelings and their
comfort and their privacy doesn't count
it all must be sacrificed on the lgbt
altar
and that is yet another reason among so
many why i say to get your kids out of
this damned godforsaken system
save them while you still can
please
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
when it comes to gift giving you know
they say that it's the thought that
counts but we all know that's that's one
of the lies we all tell each other and
we all know that it's not true it's it's
not just the thought that counts um you
know if you have to put the right
thought into the gift and really what
what matters with a gift is can i use it
do i want it is it great um and i'll
tell you one gift that you can give that
will check all those boxes it's the x
chair the chair i'm sitting in right now
how about a gift that keeps on giving
you joy and comfort every day all year
long a gift that looks as good as it
feels and a gift that will actually pay
for itself in terms of how much more
productive you'll be at work i'm talking
about giving yourself the gift not
someone else of an ex chair i absolutely
love mine it's by far the most
comfortable and ergonomic chair i've
ever used and honestly it's also
probably the coolest looking piece of
furniture that i that i own not only is
x cherry the world's greatest office
chair but with its patented lmx
technology it doubles as a massage chair
and it can either cool or warm your back
probably you've sat in many office
chairs in your time that can't do all of
that now is the perfect time to purchase
an x chair buy early buy now and here's
the ex chair holiday gift for you save
100 off your ex chair just by purchasing
at xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter
x chair
walsh.com extra has a 30-day guarantee
of complete comfort and you can finance
your purchase for as little as 30 bucks
a month go to xchairwalsh.com and save
xchairwalsh.com
all right
as we get into news here on um the matt
welsh show and i am a bestseller i don't
know if i don't know if i told you i'm a
best-selling children's author do i have
i don't even have a book where's the
book i don't have it i forgot to i
forgot to have it on on a camera with me
um
go to johnnywalrus.com we're still sold
out sold out on amazon at present but
you can go to johnthewalders.com
and uh get that book also as you can see
i am uh
fulfilling my other true calling along
with being a children's author uh and
theocratic fascists and all that and a
philanthropist and a virginian i'm also
a fashion model so i'm wearing uh some
of our matt welsh show merchandise or
the daily wire the return or die
shopping cart shirt which is another uh
best seller
um
and for good reason you know
um and we've got a whole bunch of other
merchandise there if you go to the daily
wire
and i'll be uh funneling a lot of that
stuff on that it's just going to look
really really ted it's i'm just a tacky
bastard so i'm going to be wearing the
merchandise it'll be all over the studio
i don't think any of the other hosts are
doing this like i'm the only one doing
it
it's just greedy and tacky but what can
you do
all right let's go uh let's start with
here the white house yesterday announced
a new five-point plan for kovid
a new one so they've had you know they
had their the plan before this plan
and uh and that didn't work and you know
but but that was the plan that was put
in place because the plan before that
one didn't work and that one was put
there because the one before that one
didn't work and so we keep going with
more with more but usually they're
five-point plans sometimes uh you know
sometimes it's a three-point plan
now we've got a five-point plan
in light of the omnicorn variant and
here is um
we'll watch as much of this as we can
stomach here's tony fauci explaining the
new plan
hi everyone this is tony fauci here and
the president today is going to announce
new ways how we are going to address the
kobe 19 outbreak as we enter into the
winter months particularly with the new
situation that we have now with the
omicron variant
[Music]
number one the president is launching a
campaign to get as many people boosted
as they possibly can if you're one of
the 100 million americans who are
eligible for a boost go get your booster
shot now number two in order to protect
kids and families we will be launching
family vaccination sites throughout the
country to make it easier for families
parents and children to get vaccinated
and number three is free at home tests
for americans we will be aimed at
getting home tests for american families
free tests where medical insurance for
private insurance will pay 100 percent
of the cost to get tests for individuals
who need them so that's that's that's
well so we got three we've got three the
other one is uh travel requirements so
um
there's there's uh there's new travel
requirements
and uh that is covet test for
international travelers is on there
they're also leaving open the
possibility uh eventually of domestic
travel because that's the one thing that
they have
so far they've done a lot with traveling
and they're also extending the mass
mandate on planes
into march
um and then once march i think it's like
late march and then once that comes of
course they're gonna extend it and keep
extending it in uh i believe it was in
in uh
oregon or washington oregon i think
they've
made the mass mandate permanent so and
they claim that yeah it's permanent but
it's not real it's it's like we're
making it official it's not really
permanent as in forever it's more
indefinite
we're calling it permanent but it's
indefinite
kind of the same thing so eventually
we'll get that here too with traveling
but they're still they're still
pretending that this is temporary so
they extended the mass mandate until
march
um and that's on planes and then uh and
you can go you can go get we're gonna
get everybody boosted
you got to get jabbed and boosted
and the great thing is to get jabbed and
boosted you can uh bring your kids with
you now to uh to a family vaccination
site
the fact that your kid that uh
covet poses almost no risk to your kids
statistically speaking doesn't matter
you know make it a family event
go get jabbed and boosted with the kids
give them this statistically
essentially unnecessary vaccine for them
given their
given their their their risk level which
is very very low and then i don't know
go to red robin or something or chuck e
cheese they got a whole family day
meanwhile jen posaki has a theory
related to covet
about why people are looting in places
like
san francisco is it the fact that uh all
of these places have
district attorneys
many of them um were were placed there
in part with the help of um money from
guys like george soros
is it because you've got these guys who
are not putting violent criminals in
jail is it because they've announced
ahead of time that you can steal x
amount up to x amount of uh dollars
worth of merchandise and we won't
prosecute you
is that what's leading to this
is it the collapse of the family in
these cities no no it's none of that
it's um because of the pandemic she says
listen
a huge group of criminals organizes
themselves and they want to go loot a
store a cvs nordstrom a home depot until
the shelves are clean you think that's
because of the pandemic
i think a root cause in a lot of
communities is the pandemic yes
i was hoping we'd get an explanation
there but we don't get one because
because there isn't any explosion
the pandemic has caused people has
caused mass looting
well we know that aoc told us that
people are all of the the uptick in
crime that we're hearing about is
actually just people stealing bread
i don't know it's it's
bread in the shape of like gucci bags
and uh and designer shoes apparently
because i all of the videos that you see
of the mass looting
really it's it's actually kind of
striking that uh
none of it is happening at grocery
stores
none of it involves
essential items people need to live
and even if it did that still wouldn't
make it okay obviously obvious to
to normal people anyway
but no the looting is all at um retail
outlets
you know designer outlets that sort of
thing
so she doesn't explain exactly
how the pandemic
could contribute to that
i'll tell you one way that it does we
already talked about this
she's correct in only one way that um
the masking
which has come out of the pandemic
certainly does contribute to it
so she's not wrong about that at least
all right let's move on to
the view um
in the supreme court case we know the
left is of course losing their minds
as they see the possibility that they
will um that their high sacrament of
abortion their highest and most sacred
sacrament
potentially will be desecrated
will be taken from them
but not even actually taken from them by
the way because we should remind
everyone and i i think many people still
don't realize this and if you rely on
the media to for your information the
corporate media then you're not going to
realize
that if
roe v wade is overturned that doesn't
mean that abortion is illegal across the
country the next day
i wish it meant that but that's not what
it means all it means now is that states
have the abilities to make their own
laws when it comes to abortion and so
eventually probably very quickly
abortion will be effectively illegal and
i don't know probably 20 states or
something or maybe more
but the states where most of the
abortions happen
new york california those it not only
will abortion still be in place in those
states
but what i would expect is that they're
going to respond to this by putting more
extreme abortion laws on the books
which may seem very difficult to do
because the laws of california and new
york when it comes to abortion are
already you would think as extreme as it
gets but i would not be at all surprised
uh to to to find
if roe v wade is overturned
very soon after that
the deep blue states start doing things
like
explicitly
uh
making it infanticide legal and that
sort of thing
which they've already effectively done
in new york
so they're left's freaking out about it
and the one thing that we're that we're
hearing over and over again of course is
how this is all this is an attack on on
women which is an interesting claim for
a number of reasons but first let's
listen to
uh whoopi goldberg wearing a very ugly
sweater and making this case
do any of you men
have any eggs or the possibility of
carrying a fetus how dare you talk about
what a fetus wants you have no idea
now i'm i'm fine if you disagree with
abortion i have no problem with that my
problem comes when you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you
did she say you have no idea what a
fetus wants is that what she said
are you suggesting that they that they
might want to be killed
that's something that they might want
but she also says that if you're a man
you don't have uh eggs you don't have
the ability to carry a quote-unquote
fetus before you respond to that nancy
pelosi had a similar perspective um
during her press conference let's listen
to listen to that
yesterday
the supreme court took up a very
important issue
i viewed it as listening as a very dark
day as the supreme court heard arguments
about the case of mississippi's extreme
law
the court is threatening to trample over
the constitution destroy roe v wade and
turn away
take away a woman's freedom to make the
most fundamental decision that she can
make for herself and her family working
with her family members and her doctor
and her faith
and so we have a
situation where
for us we believe the strongest weapon
that we have
here is to
pass the
roadway codification we did that already
in the
house man she is old
uh
she says this is an attack on women and
uh whoopi goldberg says the same thing
will be goldberg is more explicit about
it you know relating it to your body
saying you don't have a right to talk
about this if you don't have if you
can't if you can't carry a fetus within
your body and so on
now
we know that that's already a very
stupid point for many reasons we've
talked about plenty of times uh one
being that the body at issue is not the
woman's body that's not what we're
talking about here we're talking about
the body of the child in the womb
um that is that is the body in dispute
here that's the body whose life hangs in
the balance
also
it takes two to tango so every single
quote-unquote fetus
that is currently in the womb of a woman
was created by
with the help of a man
and so you would think that that would
mean that men actually have a stake in
in this issue
because these are our children also
they are in fact equally our children
you can't make a baby on your own
you need the 50
contribution of a man
and you would also think that we all
have a stake in it because we were all
unborn children at one time or another
you know ronald reagan's famous quote
that uh i've noticed that all the people
who support abortion are already born
now whoopi goldberg says
you don't know what the fetus wants
maybe the fetus wants to have his uh his
skull crushed
maybe he wants to be jabbed in the heart
with a poisoned needle
which is how they perform many of these
abortions especially in the later stages
maybe he wants to be ripped limb from
limb
which is also how they perform these
abortions in the later stages
maybe maybe he wants that she says
yet i'm guessing that whoopi goldberg is
quite happy that didn't happen to her
i think i could say that every single
person alive today is quite happy that
didn't happen to them
if you're if you're alive today and you
wished you were dead then you probably
would be living much longer
so you would think that would give us
all a stake in this issue
and also the fact that this is a that
this is a matter of law it's a matter of
morals so you don't have to be
personally connected to the issue
i mean if somebody uh murders a homeless
man
out in california
that doesn't directly affect me he
doesn't it doesn't it would be very hard
to argue that that has any direct impact
on me at all
i'm not involved i'm not the homeless
man maybe he wanted to be murdered
you know the person who murdered him i
don't know their reasons i don't i i'm
not walking in their shoes i haven't i
don't i don't uh i don't know about
their lived experience
and yet even though i'm not involved in
the issue and it doesn't affect me in
any way and it's none of my business i
am still very much opposed to it and i
think there should be laws against it
but all of that aside of course
the real problem
as we know is that they can't make this
point anymore
you you can't do this anymore whoopi
goldberg
because men can have eggs
and carry a babies within them
men can have uteruses
that's that's your position i have to
remind you
now i i understand whoopi goldberg as an
older woman i don't know she's what her
60s or 70s now
that's probably not actually your
position
because because you you grew up and you
were raised
before gender ideology got into the
mainstream
and so you've probably lived your entire
life
under the assumption that men are men
women are women only women have babies
only men have penises and that kind of
thing
and you probably still believe that
you probably look around at uh gender
ideology and all this kind of stuff and
you think that's crazy but you're not
going to say that out loud because you
certainly don't have the courage for
that
you are beholden to this ideology
and you're not going to speak out
against it you're not going to
contradict it
which means that you can't say this
anymore
it's it
it really works to your benefit in the
end in a certain way because it's such a
stupid point
this no uterus no opinion thing is a
it's a very stupid argument and it makes
you sound dumb now granted there are no
good arguments for abortion
but maybe you could try to find one
that's a little bit better than that
so it's for the best maybe for you
but you have to find a different
argument because this doesn't work
anymore
um the female body
is no longer exclusive to women i'm
afraid to tell you
so what you're engaging in here is rank
transphobia and it's deeply offensive
man
if that's how you identify
all right uh staying on roe v wade for a
second here i just saw this right before
showtime i want to read through it a
little bit it's a horrifying editorial
in the new york times arguing
that it's better to kill babies than
adopt them
adoption is bad is the pitch
right
so here is this is from um
elizabeth spyers who's a
democratic digital strategist
and she was adopted as an infant and her
point what's the headline
uh i was adopted i know the trauma it
can inflict
so it's a long we can't read the whole
thing let's go through a little bit of
this on wednesday as the supreme court
heard oral arguments from state
attorneys seeking to uphold
mississippi's 15-week abortion ban
justice amy coney barrett kept getting
at one question
why was abortion necessary when women
who do not want to be mothers can simply
give their babies up for adoption
as an adoptee myself i was floored by
justice barrett's assumption that
adoptionism is an accessible and
desirable alternative for women who find
themselves unexpectedly pregnant
she may not realize it but what she's
suggesting is that women
don't need access to abortion because
they simply they can simply go do a
thing that is infinitely more difficult
expensive dangerous and potentially
traumatic than terminating a pregnancy
during its early stages
as an adoptive mother herself
justice barrett should have some inkling
of the complexities of adoption and the
toll it can inflict on children as well
as birth
mothers okay i don't even where to even
begin with something like this
adoption is more dangerous
than abortion
now clearly we're only we're only
talking we're not taking the child into
account at all here yet
i don't know if we're going to get to
the point where she argues that it's
better for the child also to be
dismembered and have his skull crushed
than to be put up for adoption maybe
she'll argue that later but right now
she's talking about the woman presumably
and so she says it's it's more dangerous
for the woman to put their child up for
adoption than to get an abortion
how so there's there's no physical
danger involved whatsoever and putting
your child up for adoption
um
and and most states say this is
something that amy coney barrett talked
about
that most states or maybe every state
now
have laws on the books that make it
intentionally very very easy
for a child from for a parent to give
their child up
for adoption
so certainly not dangerous now we
compare that to abortion
even according to the leftist
euphemistic way of talking about it it's
a it's a it's a quote-unquote medical
procedure it's a quote-unquote surgery
and there are always dangers in any
surgery
and those dangers are going to outweigh
you know bringing your child somewhere
to uh to give them up for adoption
but this particular surgery is surgery
quote unquote is far more dangerous than
most
we don't we don't talk about that i mean
these are women who are erased from the
public consciousness and conversation
but there are many many women out there
thousands and thousands of women out
there if not more who have suffered um
long-lasting phys these long-lasting
physical effects of abortion
including sometimes permanent
infertility and uh and other things as
well i mean if you want to know about
the the dangers of abortion go go check
in with
gosnell the serial killer up in
philadelphia was in prison now
you know multiple women were killed by
gosnell
and he's not the only one that's done
that
and then potentially traumatic
okay so
giving your child up for adoption
is that a traumatic event
well i could certainly see that that it
that it would be
you know that's a i could see the the
emotional trauma that would be involved
in making that decision
but let's compare that to killing your
child
okay because with you the regret that
comes later you've made a decision that
cannot be reversed
so on one hand
you've given your child to another
family that can care for them
and wants to care for your child
and even in spite of all of the
emotional trauma which i'm sure
is uh is pronounced
you know that your child is out in the
world
living
and there's a chance that they could a
very good chance just like anybody else
that they could go on to live a very
happy and fulfilled and joyful life
so there's that
and then there is removing your child
from the world permanently
and then you you you
move on from that
knowing that your child your child is
nowhere and you can't go back
there is a void now where your child
once was that will never be filled
what's more traumatic we wonder
um she continues
let's see
skipping ahead a little bit
the right likes to suggest that abortion
is a traumatic experience for women a
last resort a painful memory but
adoption is often just as traumatic as
the right thinks abortion is if not more
so as a woman has to relinquish not a
lump of cells but a fully formed baby
she has lived with for nine months
i may mother myself to an adorable
six-year-old self-proclaimed
fortnite expert
and uh as is of course her six-year-old
plays fortnite obviously
no big surprise there
um and as is often the case i did not
know why would you
you're this is not the point at all i
realized but you're six-year-old
you have your six-year-old playing
fortnight
my kids barely know what a video game is
okay let's not focus on that and as is
often the case i did not know i was
pregnant with him until the usual
symptoms appeared a few weeks into
pregnancy as anyone who has just stated
a human will tell you there's a vast
difference between the fourth week of
pregnancy and the 40th by the 40th
you're familiar with your baby's regular
rhythms of kicking and moving when i
awoke my son would wake up shortly after
and i'd feel him turning and stretching
or less pleasantly jamming his precious
little foot into what felt like my
cervix this is one of the paradoxes of
pregnancy something alien is usurping
your body and sapping you of nutrition
and energy but you're programmed to
gleefully enable it and you become
desperately uh protective of it
it's she's talking about talking about
her own child now and using the word
it's
it's a kind of biological brainwashing
and this often often happens whether you
want to be a parent or not
my god
i feel so bad for this child
your own mother referring to you as as
it and saying that her love for her
child is uh is by is the product of
biological brainwashing
yeah this is how these people see
children
i said yesterday they they really they
hate children they hate babies
they hate their own kids
whatever kids they've allowed to live
they hate them and resent them
because they see this as a zero-sum game
it's a it's an us or them kind of thing
and children are usurping they're taking
away my freedom my liberty
they're taking away my autonomy they're
a burden
that's the way they see it
and so as i skim ahead in this in this
article i was waiting for her to make
the case i mean she's talking about how
adoption is better for women which is
insane
but what about the baby issue is she is
she going to try to make the case that
it's better for the baby and the answer
appears to be no because the baby
doesn't factor in at all who cares about
the baby
his needs what's best for him is is not
does not factor in we're not talking
about it who cares
because he's a non-entity
a clump of cells
as elizabeth spire puts it
all right let's move forward here
trevor noah as the kids might say has
taken a i guess a bit of a red pill
on the question of vaccines let's listen
to that
so on the one hand almost all the
omicron cases have been mild so far
but on the other hand
the guy who stands to gain millions of
dollars from new vaccines
says we need new vaccines
huh if we don't make a new vaccine this
disease could be with us ferrari i mean
forever sorry i was thinking of
something else now look i'm not saying
that the ceo of modena is lying i'm not
saying that at all i'm just saying i
don't think he's the most objective
source on this topic
i it amazes me it's the same with
watching the view and i watch the clips
of the view i've never seen a whole
episode
only see the clips and also the the
daily show now um in the post jon
stewart era
do people actually sit and watch that
because i agree with what he's saying
but even in
in agreeing i find myself cringing
because of that terrible ferrari joke
this is uh this is supposed to be a
comedy show
but it took him you know what is it uh
so we're 18 months i mean we're almost
two years into this
and he's he's finally realizing that uh
there might be some conflicts of
interest here
is he going to get dinged is this this
misinformation is this uh
coveted trutherism
no yeah it should be a pretty obvious
conclusion here
that there that there are conflicts of
interest
that's that's that's a financial reality
you have to take that reality into
account
every day in your life
you know you go to get you go you take
your car to the mechanic
it doesn't mean you can't trust any
mechanics but what you have to remember
is that they are getting paid obviously
and so they have a vested interest in
convincing you that you need work on
your car that you might not need
that's not a conspiracy theory
but what we're being told is that is
that everything you just heard from
trevor noah i'm sure he'll get a pass
but what you just heard there is a
conspiracy theory no it's not
this is a recognition of human nature
when there's money on the line even if
it's not that much money
there's an incentive for people to be
less than honest
that's the case for a car mechanic
you need new tires or something
we just had this last week you need one
new tire you take the car and you get
one new tire and what do you know they
tell you you know what actually you need
you need all four new tires and we don't
have we don't have the use tires that
you need so you need to get brand new
ones that'll be five times as expensive
now let's go over to the pharmaceutical
industry where there are billions and
billions of dollars at stake
do we think that maybe there might be a
conflict of interest and that's
something to keep in mind
that's that's the grain of salt
that you apply to everything they tell
you
all right next alec baldwin was
interviewed by george snuffalopis on abc
and uh we'll play just one clip of this
maybe two probably one he's asked about
uh whether he feels any guilt for having
shot and killed a woman
which he did do
and he doesn't deny it now at one point
in the interview he denies pulling the
trigger
he says he that
i don't know he doesn't he doesn't
really explain what happened i mean how
did the gun go off if you didn't pull
the trigger
again if you listen to corporate media
you might think that that sort of thing
happens because you think that guns
are responsible for murder and gun
violence and everything that's why we
call it gun violence it's not violence
perpetrated by people but by the tools
they're using and so you might think
that guns just have a mind of their own
and they go off all the time but that's
that's not the case guns go off if you
pull the trigger
he says he didn't pull it
and maybe that's why he now says that he
also feels no guilt at all for what
happened
your emotions are so clearly so
right there on the surface you felt
shock
you felt anger
you felt sadness
do you feel guilt
no
no
i feel that there is i i feel that that
that
someone is responsible
for what happened and i can't say who
that is but i know it's not me baldwin
now awaiting the outcome of the
sheriff's investigation
hoping whatever it uncovers helps to
ensure a tragedy like this never happens
again
[Music]
what do we come out of this learning
what do we come out of it what changes
can be made because where you have a
person
where where as i said this is one in a
billion
that someone puts a real bullet in the
gun
that never happens and the idea that a
real bullet was in that gun and would
come out of that gun and kill them that
was
not even in the realm of possibility and
that's the thing that they must find out
is where who brought bullets onto the
set
amazing
what do we learn he asks what do we
learn from this well one thing we learn
is don't give alec baldwin a gun that's
that's one thing we learn
and then he actually says this is this
is one of the most honest things i think
you'll ever hear from a hollywood actor
and the only honest thing in that entire
interview that you heard
uh
he says uh he says uh it
i don't know who's responsible
someone is responsible i don't know who
but i just know it's not me
is that not a perfect distillation of
the way these people go about life and
so many others
i don't know who's responsible for this
you know
someone's accountable all i know is that
it's not my fault i was the one holding
the gun
that went off somehow mysteriously
probably because i moved my finger in a
certain way while pressing the trigger
i'm not responsible for that at all he
says
oh okay we'll play one more clip he says
uh i guess explaining why he's not
responsible uh
then the question is raised about well
why didn't you check the gun when it was
handed to you and he says that uh hey
actors that's not the actor's job to
check the gun
how do you respond to actors like george
clooney who say that every time they
were handed a gun they checked it
themselves well there were a lot of
people who felt it necessary to
contribute some comment to the situation
which really didn't help the situation
at all
you have your if your protocol is you
checking the gun every time well good
for you good for you
i mean i probably handled weapons as
much as any other actor in films
with an average career again shooting or
being shot by someone and in in that
time i had a protocol and it never let
me down
why did you choose in your 40 years not
to check the gun yourself
what i was taught by someone years ago
was
as i said if i if i took a gun
and i popped a clip out of a gun or i
manipulated the chamber of a gun they
would take the gun away from me and redo
it
the prop person said don't do that
when i was young and they'd say
one thing you need to understand is we
don't want the actor to be the last line
of defense against a catastrophic breach
of safety with the gun
my job they told me man or woman
my job is to make sure the gun is safe
and then i hand you the gun and i
declare the gun safe the crew's not
relying on you to say that it's safe
they're relying on me to say that it's
safe
no this is not just so you know uh he
says well hey if
if those were your personal protocols
that you checked the gun that you're
handed then then good for you yeah we
all have our own we all have our own
protocols for guns no no we don't
there is a a universal standards of gun
safety when it comes you know across the
entire world universal gun safety
standards not always followed as
evidenced by alec baldwin but they exist
and one of them is
that you always check it
always check it
and you never point the gun
at anyone or anything you don't want to
shoot
that's another one
universal standards
so all he's telling i can't believe this
guy is a hollywood actor
insanely rich i'm sure he's got all he's
got lawyers
i'm sure he has a team of 50 lawyers
right now on the case here
and they let him do this interview
because his excuse basically is that
he's been reckless for 40 years
and so why not be reckless now
and he says that uh well you don't want
the actor to be the last line of defense
that's
yeah that's true i mean you never want
to be in a situation where someone hands
you a gun and says that it's not loaded
but it is
that's that's that's you never you never
want that you don't want the actor to be
the last line of defense
but
it's better than the alternative which
is that the actor doesn't act as that
last line of defense at all and just
shoots the gun and kills somebody
ah but he says that this is uh
we're not helping with our opinions
can you imagine saying that you shoot
and kill someone
and then other people criticize you
and you kind of turn your nose up and
say
your opinions aren't helping the
situation
my god
no surprise though to have this kind of
narcissism in a hollywood actor i
suppose all right let's get now to the
comment section
[Music]
resident wiseacre uh says when people
start adding qualifiers to what makes
one alive then we can only assume that
they would never apply those same
qualifiers to themselves yeah as as we
just talked about that that of course
is the case every single every single
pro-abortion person
is quite happy that their own arguments
were not applied to them
because they but
it's they're an exception because they
are important people and the world
desperately needed them
the world desperately needed the
contributions of one whoopi goldberg and
so of course she should not have been
aborted but uh but all these other
babies clumps of cells who cares we got
killed 60 million of them let's kill
another 60 million it means nothing
kayla says i was at the slu talk sorry
the slew talk
i was at the sloo talk and i knew you
were serious when you said you tried to
talk to the protesters on the way home i
try to convince my mom who came with me
that's that that's something you would
do but she isn't sweet baby gang like me
and she said it was too dangerous for
you to confront the crazies and was so
sure you were kidding i was happy to rub
it in when the footage was posted well
um
you know i would ban your mom from the
show for that but it sounds like she
doesn't watch anyway and also i can't
blame her as a mom
uh for for feeling that way you know
that this would be a very stupid
and reckless thing to do there's no way
he would have done that
but of course i did do it
and i and i will admit that uh you know
some of the women in my life or were
perhaps not
huge fans of that decision on my part so
i'll let your mom off the hook
jessica says
matt you scallywag i was at uh slu
yesterday for your event garbed in my
sweet baby gang t-shirt for which i paid
roughly 4982
and you didn't even stick around to take
pictures or sign merch
this is an outrage and i demand you give
me your home address so that i can send
my sbg shirt to be autographed um in
fact i i did i was there i did stick
around and we were doing pictures and
everything i don't know where you were
okay i was waiting around waiting around
for you jessica you didn't show up so
you're banned from the show i i hate to
say
um
clint says as a defense contractor i too
travel a lot and spend many nights in
hotels my greatest wish is to be in the
room next door and hear you do your show
it would be good to have someone
friendly next door i guess i i do think
about that every time i'm doing the show
because i'm always shouting when i do
the show and that's my that's my camera
voice and i'm always thinking that you
know the walls are thin at hotels and i
always feel sorry for the people around
us who can certainly hear the entire
thing why should i feel sorry for them
they get a they get a sneak preview of
the show
um
and uh
another comment says does your makeup
artist get her own hotel suite when
you're traveling
no the makeup artist is sean my producer
when we're traveling and we don't talk
about it um
we don't talk about it it's not
discussed
this is not something we'll ever discuss
again as you know we don't talk about
the fact that sweet daddy wears makeup
we don't talk about it and now
everyone's favorite time time for the
daily wire promos in this case i'll tell
you about uh things i've already told
you about during the show uh johnny the
walrus is the book that's on sale right
now we sold out on amazon in the first
day
which i i don't know if this is true or
not but i gotta think we have one of the
the fastest selling children's books
ever i don't know as long as we're not
carrying counting harry potter as a
children's book then maybe i can
possibly make that claim by the way we
sold out at amazon in a day and uh now
we are uh on johnnywallers.com just go
to johnnywalrus.com and get your book
today also
if you haven't already you should go
check out our new merch store over at
dailywire.com shop while you're there
get your hands on a let's go brandon
trucker hat or a do not comply t-shirt
or you could get the return or die shirt
that i'm wearing right now order now and
get it in time for christmas and get a
sweet discount on those daily wire
original collections that's
dailywire.comshop
go check it out immediately now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know i am i am no historian but one
thing i have noticed when i read about
human civilizations of the past is that
they were all comprised of humans
seems evident from my study of the
subject that you can't have a human
civilization without humans the most
basic purpose of a civilization is to
propagate itself not the only purpose
but one of the most basic just as the
most basic biological purpose of each
individual human is to reproduce
so it follows that a civilization which
gives up on producing humans will
inevitably collapse
and that's why i am
worried about the trend in the west
towards childish childlessness and
childishness i guess as our fertility
rate drops below replacement level we
more and more resemble a society that
has basically given up on itself
we are people who have lost interest in
people
a civilization that has despaired of
itself
a survey from pew research center this
week provides more detail on this trend
msn reports quote a growing share of u.s
adults who aren't already parents say
they probably won't have children citing
reasons such as apathy financial
instability or the lack of a partner
a new survey from the pew research
center found that 44
of non-parents ages 18 to 49 says it's
not too likely or not at all likely that
they will have children someday an
increase of seven percentage points from
the 37 who said the same in 2018 the
survey doesn't bode well for a reversal
of the downward trend in u.s fertility
rates which have been hammered by the
public health and economic crises caused
by the pandemic the number of babies
born in the country fell four percent to
about 3.6 million in 2020 the largest
decline since 1973. although the reasons
for not having children very sharply the
main one given by childless adults is
simply that they don't want any
other reasons given include medical at
19 and financial at 17 about 15 cite the
lack of a partner 10 said it was the age
of their partner 9 blame the state of
the world roughly 1 in 20 cite
environmental factors including climate
change as the reasons behind their
desire to not have a child which only
just supports what i've said before that
like no one actually cares about climate
change
um
uh continuing among adults under 40 who
are already parents about one quarter
don't expect to have more children due
to the financial cost involved while
three and ten say they're too old
okay so the survey says that 17 percent
cite financial concerns for their
decision to remain childless
indefinitely but i would guess that the
real portion is much higher than that
i'm not sure i've ever spoken to a
childless adult about this subject
without them mentioning finances as at
least one of the reasons for their
childless lifestyle choice so i think
it's worth responding to that specific
objection in some detail
first of all it's almost certainly not
true
that you can't afford to have kids
because there's no income requirement
for parenthood you don't need to pay any
monthly subscription fee
plenty of people poorer than you not
only have kids but have them and live
quite happily and comfortably
you know it's in in many ways
having kids is about as expensive as you
make it
you have a whole and there there are
expenses that come up obviously as a
parent that you have no control over but
on a day-to-day basis you have a whole
lot of leeway in how expensive this is
going to be
just like you have a leeway and how
expensive your own life is going to be
so it's not that you can't afford
children it's that you can't afford your
current lifestyle once you have added
children into the bargain so it's a
matter of priority not raw cost per se
but all of life is a series of
trade-offs and this is no exception in
this case
the trade-off is more material
possessions and financial security in
exchange for being alone and leaving no
lasting legacy when you die
will your material possessions
your stuff your inanimate objects
will all of us bring you the kind of joy
and fulfillment that you can derive from
a family
given that joy and fulfillment are what
we all fundamentally desire and pursue
this is the big question and i think the
answer is no
i'll put it to you this way but you know
i was traveling again this week
when i'm on the road i miss my kids and
my wife i i don't miss the stuff at my
house
my wife sends me pictures of the kids
when i'm gone she doesn't send me
pictures of the couch or the tv
there's a connection with other humans
with your family your children your wife
that brings you a sort of joy and
purpose that you just can't find
anywhere else
parenthood is also transformational
having kids changes you for the better
or at least it should
i mean it doesn't for everyone but it
should
it gives you the opportunity for that
maybe we should say
there are very few like threshold
moments in your life
where something happens a change occurs
you walk through a door and you're never
the same again there are plenty of
moments where you think everything is
changing and you're changing but you're
not
so you go on vacation and you travel and
it's amazing and you feel like it's
changed your perspective on life
and then within 36 hours of being home
you're the same person again
but having kids is different
that's one of those crossing the rubicon
type moments
should you forfeit that for monetary
reasons
another thing to keep in mind is that
you may take a step back and lifestyle
when you have kids but that's that's not
necessarily a permanent situation i'm in
a much better financial position better
position in terms of lifestyle today
with four kids than i was before i had
kids
you might say that well if i never had
kids i'd be doing even better
financially
maybe i mean you know we can't know but
probably not because the other thing
that kids do for you
is they give you a sense of purpose and
ambition that's hard to muster and stir
up within yourself just purely of your
own accord
i've taken chances that i wouldn't have
taken if i didn't have a family defeat
i've invested myself in projects that i
probably wouldn't have taken on if i
didn't have a family depending on me i
made sacrifices that i wouldn't have
made without a family to make them for
i'm a better person in many ways
than i would be
if i did not have kids looking up to me
and modeling themselves after me
i'm still not a great person but
certainly better than the alternative
it's not a coincidence i think that
people are giving up on kids in our
culture
and they're also giving up on everything
else
10 million open jobs that nobody wants
to take workers dropping out of the
workforce grown adults living at home
with their parents and so on
we aren't seeing that people forego
families and then go out into the work
world and obsessively pursue their
ambitions
that still wouldn't be the right way to
live in my opinion but that's not what's
happening
what we find more often is that people
give up on kids
and soon everything else follows in the
end it's hard to
we find in the end it's hard to live for
other people but it's harder to live for
yourself
there are sacrifices you have to make
for your family many of them monetary
but if you don't have anyone to
sacrifice for then eventually you just
run out of reasons to try
at all
that's what we're that's what we're
witnessing in our culture today
and that's why i urge you again as i
have many times in the past and will
many times in the future and as god
commanded in genesis
be fruitful and multiply
you'll figure out the financial part of
it trust me you will
so who is canceled today um i suppose
people who choose money over children
are ultimately cancelled
and once again of course i have to
cancel those who um i mean of all the
financial obligations one that is that
is uh that is not an option
um
this is not discretionary spending that
is buying johnny the walrus at
johnnywalrus.com so make sure you do
that also or you're canceled and we'll
leave it there for today and the week
have a great weekend talk to you on
monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin